Dr. Jack Bright was having the second-worst
day of his life, and things weren’t about
to get better.
He ran down the main hall of Site-19, medallion
jangling against his chest.
All around him, sirens blared and warning
lights flashed a stark, threatening red.
He cursed and muttered under his breath.
Just an hour ago, things had been under control,
neat and orderly, standard running operations,
and now they were staring down the barrel
of both a Broken Masquerade Scenario and a
potential XK Class End of the World Scenario.
And on a more personal level, four of the
meanest, nastiest, and deadliest anomalies
were on his tail.
They’d breached containment, compromised
site security, and now they were out for revenge.
What was happening?
How had this group of anomalies gotten out,
and why were they all after Dr. Bright?
And most importantly of all, how could everything
have gone to hell in a handbasket so fast?
Let’s rewind the clock and see.
The morning had begun in the break room.
Dr. Bright was enjoying a nice cup of hot
coffee and a danish, watching the news.
It was, by all accounts, an incredibly boring
day.
The reports were economic figures, a few dry
statistics about unemployment, and then live
coverage of a presidential press conference
on the White House lawn.
Dr. Bright was halfway through a thought about
how he’d hated his brief period of time
inhabiting the body of George W. Bush and
running the country when the president started
melting over his podium on live TV.
As well as his guards.
And the press corps.
And the camera people.
It was a sight so shocking it made Dr. Bright
drop his coffee cup, and almost drop his danish!
He slipped out his phone and fired off a text
to O5-1, the leader of the O5 Council, simply
saying, “We may have a problem.”
To which he received the quick and emphatic
reply, “YOU THINK!?”
Dr. Bright started frantically changing the
channel.
He wanted to know if some anomalous troublemaker
had just melted the President and those around
him, perhaps to destabilize the US government
- that’d be a textbook Chaos Insurgency
move - or if they were looking at something
considerably more dangerous.
And considering every single channel Dr. Bright
changed to started displaying a “Signal
Interrupted” message, now was probably not
the time to be optimistic.
It was here.
The big one.
The one they’d all been waiting for.
Battle stations: Engaged.
Across Site-19, the protocols were enacted
to put everything on total lockdown: Nobody
in, nobody out.
It was lucky for everyone inside that hadn’t
already been exposed that this protocol also
involved the automatic shuttering of every
single window in the building.
Dr. Bright and a crack team of senior researchers
and administrators gathered in the site’s
command center and opened up a live video
link to O5-1.
They might make some sense of all this chaos
now, and figure out a good battle plan.
“So, what’s the situation, boss?”
Dr. Bright asked.
O5-1 let out a deep, rattling sigh.
“Well, Jack, things are about as bad as
they ever have been, so I’ll try my best
to take inventory.
A quarter of the council is gone - They got
exposed and stopped reporting in during the
initial shift.
That includes O5-9 on the orbiting base, given
she probably got the most direct exposure.”
A senior administrator raised their hand and
asked, “Exposure to what, sir?”
O5-1 took a grave pause before saying...
“Sunlight.
That seems to be what we’re up against here.
The one common denominator that seems to connect
everyone experiencing these anomalous effects
is direct sunlight exposure.
It causes people to take on a kind of... gelatinous
state.
And it isn’t just people, either.
It’s all living anomalies, too.
Something about this new sun thing, it’s
almost like it cancels out all previous anomalous
effects.
The only anomalies that seem to be exempt
are the ones who aren’t even made out of
flesh.”
Dr. Bright, who had a tendency to make jokes
as an emotional defense mechanism when things
got tough, chimed in with, “On a semi-related
note, anyone here feel like taking the lizard
for a walk?”
The few nervous chuckles in the room were
cut off by O5-1 slamming his fist against
the table over the video link.
Everyone fell into deathly silence.
“Damn it, Jack, this is no laughing matter!
The Foundation, and the rest of the human
race, is decimated right now.
We’re looking at billions dead already,
or at least, changed.
And even our people, a good portion of them
are reading the tea leaves and abandoning
their posts to spend what could be their last
hours with their families.
It’s imperative we take control of this
situation right now.
It may be our last chance.
So get your asses in gear and make it happen!”
And with that, the video link was cut off,
and the ragtag leaders of Site-19 got to work.
Taking what they knew about this lethal new
scenario, Dr. Bright had his subordinates
record and release one of the most significant
videos of the 21st century, or perhaps even
all of time, to be broadcasted on every communication
channel the Foundation could possibly hijack:
TV, radio, social media, YouTube, Twitch,
all global news outlets.
The SCP Foundation was going public.
People all over the world - huddled in the
dark, terrified of the horrors they’d seen
through windows or out of the safety of shady
corners - noticed that all the screens around
them started playing the same thing in perfect
synchronicity.
It was flashing red, with an unfamiliar logo,
while a commanding voice droned on with the
only instructions that might give them hope
for survival.
“This is a Public Service Announcement from
the SCP Foundation.
We are commandeering all broadcast channels
and frequencies to deliver a vital message.
Avoid sunlight at all costs.
Cover your bodies thoroughly.
And follow the instructions on the screen
to reach the nearest operational SCP Foundation
containment site…”
Back at Site-19, Dr. Bright and everyone they
had left were preparing for a sudden influx
of refugees from the outside.
Any members of D-Class personnel who weren’t
psychopathic killers were deputized as honorary
Foundation personnel and brought in to help
convert empty wings into sleeping and living
areas.
Bright, who was still trying to hold on to
some semblance of humor in this dark time,
thought to himself, “Well if I knew we were
going to be entertaining guests, I would have
cleaned the place up a little more.
Maybe bought some new throw pillows and a
scented candle or two.”
And make no mistake, it was indeed an incredibly
dark time.
It had only been a few hours since the phenomenon
started, and already, it was Hell out there.
Society had already effectively collapsed
during the chaos.
The streets were filled with the shambling
remains of melted nightmare people.
The sun shone far above like some all-powerful
tyrant, gazing its single, deadly eye down
on all of humanity.
For billions upon billions of years, it had
given this solar system life.
Now, all it had for them was death and destruction.
For those trapped outside, there was only
one hope of survival: Getting to one of these
“SCP Foundation” containment sites.
At least those people somehow knew what was
going on here...
Little did these unfortunate refugees of a
horribly and irreparably changed world know,
that all was not well in the world of the
SCP Foundation.
As the hours marched on, Broken Masquerade
scenario and possible XK aside, it seemed
to Dr. Bright that they actually had a handle
on the situation, all things considered.
And what’s more, the night was about to
fall, allowing for free movement outside.
This would be a boon for people hoping to
reach Site-19 with minimal risk of exposure.
But refugees wouldn’t be the only thing
coming to Site-19 that day.
Hours earlier and miles away, something terrible
happened at Containment Area 25b - an extensive
and heavily guarded containment site with
only one inmate.
During the initial panic of the event that
they were now codenaming When Day Breaks,
many of the guards were exposed, and several
others abandoned their posts in panic, knowing
that the world as they had all grown to know
it had come to an end.
This left the place grievously under-guarded.
200 meters under the sea, in the true heart
of the containment area, an obsidian coffin
was surrounded by a confused and terrified
skeleton crew.
And the term “Skeleton Crew” was about
to take on a far more literal meaning, as
the obsidian coffin they were trying in vain
to keep contained started to rattle.
Fast forward by twenty minutes and every single
member of Foundation personnel at Containment
Area 25b was dead, and SCP-076-2, the legendary
immortal warrior, Able, was standing in the
ruins of the base.
While it would be easy to write Able off as
a mindless killing machine because of the
sheer ferocity he brings to a battle, the
reality couldn’t be further from the case.
He had the kind of tactical intelligence that
human supercomputers wouldn’t develop for
another several centuries - if the world hadn’t
ended already.
From the visual evidence he’d gleaned upon
escaping, he already knew that sunlight had
turned deadly, turning everyone who was exposed
into these feeble blobs.
So, if he hoped to continue his killing frenzy
elsewhere, he’d need to create his own shade
during transit.
That would be simple enough.
With a cruel smirk, Able picked up one of
the reinforced blast doors he’d so easily
burst through earlier.
The sheer weight of it would have crushed
a mortal man, but for Able, this was little
more than a light workout.
He lifted the door above his head like a parasol,
bathing himself in the cool shade, before
taking off at impossible speeds.
He’d remembered a lot from his days under
the Foundation’s employ as part of the disastrous
Pandora’s Box Mobile Task Force, and one
of those things was the location of Site-19.
There’d be plenty of warriors for him to
send to their makers there...
Back at Site-19, where Able would very shortly
arrive, Dr. Bright and his team were helping
the first wave of outsiders into the confines
of the building.
At first, it had seemed like a good idea,
something they could sustain, but now, Dr.
Bright was starting to worry about all the
practical considerations.
How would they keep potentially thousands,
or even tens of thousands of people, fed,
clothed, and watered for an extended period
of time?
Sure, they had the infinite pizza box, but
pizza for three meals a day for weeks on end
was a fast track to everyone here dying of
scurvy.
These new worries were interrupted by a siren
that signaled familiar ones: There had been
a containment breach in several cells in the
humanoid containment wings.
Some of the low-risk or even friendly humanoids,
like SCP-343, aka God, had been let out to
assist in gathering survivors from the nighttime
chaos outside.
That meant anyone still locked up really,
really, really needed to stay locked up.
In other words, it was very bad news.
Dr. Bright cursed under his breath and instructed
his subordinates to keep focusing on the refugee
situation.
He shouldered an assault rifle and took off
into the bowels of the site, hoping he could
at least head off the escapees until some
guards or Mobile Task Forces from smaller
sites could reach Site-19 and help him in
getting them fully recontained.
This is just typical, he thought to himself.
When it rains, it pours.
We can never catch a break around here, can
we?
I should have followed my dreams and become
a competitive ice dancer, then I never would
have—
Dr. Bright’s self-pity was interrupted by
a brutal punch to the side of his head, which
laid him out against the wall.
He turned, vision swimming, and raised his
assault rifle, hoping to find a target in
the blur.
That’s when an obsidian blade swung at impossible
speed and cleaved his gun in half.
He could feel his breath hitch in his throat
as his vision recentered itself and he saw
the imposing, tattooed figure of Able standing
above him, wielding one of his trademark swords.
His dark eyes were burning with deadly intent.
“Hello, Jack,” he said.
“Long time no see.
I imagine I don’t need to remind you who
I am.”
Able laughed and Dr. Bright felt his muscles
tense in rage.
Of course, he knew Able.
Not only had the homicidal maniac been a consistent
thorn in the Foundation’s side since day
one, but he’d also been the one to change
Dr. Bright’s life forever.
It had been Able who had killed him as a junior
researcher when he was first carrying the
SCP-963 medallion.
It was Able who had cursed him with this terrible
immortality.
Dr. Bright despised him to his core.
“I’d like you to meet a few friends I
made since I got here, Jack,” Able said,
gesturing into the darkness of the hallway.
“Who said I was bad at teamwork?”
It was like something out of a nightmare.
First, SCP-106 stepped forward, dripping with
that terrible, black tar.
His face twisted into a manic grin that foretold
inhuman tortures to come.
Then came SCP-953, the devilish Polymorphic
Humanoid, claws and fangs bared, tails swaying.
And then, bafflingly, SCP-2430, the Immortal
Hitler Clone.
Dr. Bright tried to move but found the tip
of Able’s sword right in front of his face.
“It’s funny, Jack,” Able said.
“You’re an anomaly who kills to live.
How many people have worn your little necklace?
And yet you can swan around as you please,
while we rot away in containment.
We think it’s time for a little payback.”
Bright nodded.
“That makes sense, I guess.
But why’s he here?”
He pointed to the Immortal Hitler Clone, who
sneered, as usual.
“He thinks you’re Jewish,” said the
Polymorphic Humanoid, in Korean.
Dr. Bright rose uneasily to his feet, honestly
surprised that Able was allowing him to do
so.
He was lucky, in a sense.
It perhaps took a being as strong as Able
to hold these others at bay.
As much as Dr. Bright despised the man, he
offered a much quicker and more painless death
than the Old Man or the Polymorphic Humanoid.
It wouldn’t be anything he hadn’t experienced
before, after all.
Life could be a sick joke sometimes.
”So, what’s the plan?
You’re gonna kill me again?”
Dr. Bright asked.
The four nightmarish anomalies all began to
laugh.
“Well, in the end, yes,” Able said.
“But the world’s gone to hell.
Your people aren’t in control here anymore,
so we can take our time.
We will slaughter you and everyone else in
here.
If I were you, I’d run, Jack.”
He didn’t need to be told twice.
Jack ran for his life, too scared to even
look behind him as the sound of footsteps
got louder.
The only way things could possibly get worse
is if he somehow, amidst all this, suddenly
developed a hernia.
And the way this day was going, he really
wouldn’t have been surprised.
Dr. Bright turned a corner, and somehow, the
Polymorphic Humanoid was already there, standing
in front of him.
She gave a girlish giggle and swiped at him,
leaving four ragged claw marks on his chest.
Dr. Bright winced in pain and started running
in the other direction.
He reached an adjoining hallway and booked
it for the armory, hoping there he’d get
some serious firepower.
But SCP-106 suddenly phased through the wall
next to him, grabbing Dr. Bright by his lab
coat and throwing him against the opposite
wall with a flick of his wrist.
Bright scrambled to discard the coat, already
being eaten away by the Old Man’s caustic
fluids.
The Old Man just watched him and chuckled,
faintly amused at the whole affair.
These damn anomalies were in control now.
Dr. Bright got up and kept running.
The one saving grace was the fact that all
of these anomalies were too sadistic to outright
kill him just yet, so he still had the faintest
of chances.
He ran into the break room, tipping over shelves,
bookcases, and furniture to obstruct the path
behind him even slightly.
That’s when he heard the door behind him
open, followed by a wave of furious German
expletives as the Immortal Hitler Clone entered
the room to give chase.
However, moments later, Hitler fell to the
ground, clutching his foot and wailing in
agony.
You see, due to the circumstances of his creation
- Josef Stalin, Sarkic wizards, it was a whole
thing, we can’t get into it now - he felt
pain at three times the intensity of a normal
human being.
“Lieber Gott, I stubbed mein toe!” he
yelled.
Dr. Bright kept running.
From the break room, he entered a hallway
that would lead him back to the main barracks.
Perhaps there, he could get some reinforcements.
Then maybe he could—
His thoughts were once again cut off by Able
suddenly appearing and grabbing him by the
throat.
His grip was impossibly strong; Dr. Bright
was already seeing stars.
“Think you could get away that easily?”
Able hissed.
With horrifying strength, Able slammed Dr.
Bright up against one of the shuttered windows.
He struck it with such force he broke through
the shutter and the glass behind it, sailing
down to the ground outside.
They were lucky it was nighttime, or this
all would have been over already.
Able soon followed him down, cracking his
knuckles and assuming a fighting stance.
“Up on your feet, Jack,” Able said.
“I won’t kill a man lying down.
No honor in that.”
Jack rose, feeling pain in every inch of his
body.
Up against a seven-foot-tall, jacked monster
of a man with thousands of years of fighting
under his belt?
He stood mathematically zero chance.
But perhaps he could at least get some licks
in.
He ran at Able, screaming with years of pent-up
rage, and tried to attack him with a flurry
of blows.
But not a single one of them landed.
Able dodged every punch and returned them
with a force comparable to being hit by a
runaway train.
He knocked Dr. Bright to the ground and started
beating him relentlessly.
“All these lives I’ve given you, all this
extra time, and still, you haven’t learned
how to fight.
Pathetic!”
Able roared, punctuating his words with blows.
“Perhaps in a thousand years, you might
last sixty seconds against me.
You are a waste of your gift!”
Dr. Bright could already feel the life leaving
his body when something new entered the equation.
He could barely make it out through his bloody,
swollen eyes, but something huge was coming
toward them.
It was like flesh from so many of the melted
people had coagulated into some huge, mountainous
blob.
It was a sight so remarkable and horrifying
that even Able was distracted.
And Dr. Bright took advantage of the one chance
that gave him.
He took off his medallion and threw it at
the mass.
The life left his old body as SCP-963 deleted
the collection of tortured minds that made
up the terrible flesh monster, a nd replaced
them with only one: Dr. Jack Bright.He felt
new immense, monstrous strength well up through
him.
He was in the body of a true abomination,
and all of its power was his now.
“How about a round two, Able?” he thought.
The ancient warrior produced a pair of ebony
swords as Dr. Bright sent a swarm of fleshy
tendrils at him.
Able was quick, slicing off many of them,
but there was only so much he could take.
Soon, Dr. Bright’s new body was grabbing
Able’s every appendage, holding him in place
as he struggled with all his anomalous might.
But now, Dr. Bright’s rage had meaning,
with this new power to back it up.
He’d get a little revenge, at long last.
Time to go back in the box, Able...
It took longer than it would for any mortal
man, but eventually, it happened all the same.
Bright pushed and pulled in every direction,
applying every kind of pressure, leveraging
every ounce of his terrible new mass onto
Able’s body, until...
Crunch.
Dr. Bright relaxed his new body in final,
cathartic relief, dropping Able’s corpse
to the ground.
There was no denying, after everything that’d
happened, that it felt really, really, really
good.
The world may have ended, but at least Dr.
Bright got one win today.
Now go check out “DR.
BRIGHT FOR PRESIDENT SCP-4444 - Bush v. Gore”
and “SCP-963 What Would You Do If You Were
Immortal Like Dr. Jack Bright?” for more
strange battles and adventures from the amazing
Dr. Bright!